the one thing i don't know and maybe you
can answer this question for me because
i know you want to talk about this
giannis thing and giannis meeting with
the owner the owner says hey we're going
to push the luxury tax we go we're going
to spend some money and get you some
support
uh even though he does have support i
think
i don't think their roster is untalented
um
no i don't but this this is what i want
to know who's jan is cool with because
when you think about super teams
if you go back and look at them like
recently the last 10 or 15 years you can
kind of perform
you can predict where it's going i mean
hey we played in the olympics together
at least in hindsight you could predict
at least in hindsight
or
aau ball or something you know we got
the same age you know we vacation
together all those super teams
it's usually some type of relationship
is giannis cool with any i don't know do
you know like who's he cool with no no
i'm not i'm not sure and i don't think
look oh
you know reading between the lines of
unfollowing people aside you know i
don't think you say something
when you say something like
on command i think it was he said this
to chris haynes shout out to chris
haynes when you say something on command
such as some people see a wall and go
around it or go the other way i go
through it i mean you don't say
something like that without having given
some thought to your future with one
year left and a super max contract
staring you in the face so i don't think
you say something like that and then
reverse course and and tell ownership
i'm not going to be here you might want
to trade me now but also you may not
know you know what i mean like i mean
you ask oklahoma city how that goes you
know what i mean sometimes they may they
don't know what sometimes they know when
this don't tell you and then they see
what you do and then they walk anyway so
ultimately i'm just enjoying the
speculation even though i think it'll be
a move point pretty soon but to you to
answer your question about who he's cool
with i don't know but i'm seeing heat
i'm seeing raptors i'm seeing mavs i'm
seeing warriors i'm saying celtics i'm
seeing clippers so i'm just saying i'm
just here for the story i'm just here
for this i'm here for the speculation
but to go back to you what you said you
said you think they're talented you
think they're a talent you don't think
they're no
i want to ask you something i want to
ask you about that i want to unpack that
for a second because i was actually
going to ask you the question
everybody's looking at what they've done
this year and under achievement
especially back and forth excuse me
back-to-back years of being a number one
seed and not and not getting you know to
the finals would we or will we look at
them losing to miami differently
should miami beat boston
and make the finals interesting maybe
this was about how good miami is
yeah uh i would be surprised look okay
to answer your question yes we'll look
at it differently i'll be shocked if
that happens
now
that that that's going to take something
quite miraculous
honestly for miami to be boston
for miami to beat boston and didn't you
say get to the finals oh the answer okay
yeah right
to make the finals interesting yeah i'll
make the finals interesting okay right
so miami beating miami beating boston
would not be miraculous although it's an
upset i think i think boston is more
talented but miami
is is more experienced
but getting to the miami getting to the
finals and competing for a championship
that'd be tough so yeah we'll look at it
differently but let's go back to this
you know giannis you're talking about a
uh
mvp he's going to be mvp again this year
he's a defensive player of the year
he's got an all-nba player and middleton
on his side he's got an all-defense
player like eric bledsoe on his side i
mean it's not they gotta move him they
gotta move here
okay all right fine you're not eric
bledsoe fan that doesn't matter
what i'm saying is
you finished with the best record in the
nba two years in a row it's not that you
lack talent
you know maybe
maybe you lack a piece it might be the
head coach
i don't know what it is
but
how do you look at okay how do you look
at my i look at milwaukee and say
all right
we need to bring in what two or three
different players i mean how
how far we're going to say i i'll take
that even farther i'll take that a step
farther you have you've forgotten more
about basketball and i'll ever know so
i don't know how much you can actually
take away from anything that happened in
this bubble
i mean we've had meaningful
conversations about mental health
no no i'm just saying i'm just saying
it's like it's just
such a sure
yeah it's just such an experiment you
know i mean and even like okay you fight
for the number one seed
to get home court advantage throughout
the playoffs
you know what i mean like it has gone on
court
and you're in a bubble and it's just
everything about this is weird you know
what i mean so i i'm not saying that you
know i'm not taking anything away from
anybody that's won so far because at the
end of the day you know the teams for
the most part and the players for the
most part that are supposed to perform
more performing but i don't know that
you can be seeing it in houston as well
look houston wasn't going to beat lebron
and anthony davis wherever it was played
but none whatever that series was played
but nonetheless
it's just a lot of people are trying to
make these indictments or or or
proclamations about what a team is and
what it isn't based on how to perform in
a playoff ball but i just don't know
that's entirely fair